[Musique]
j'ai toujours voulu sortir avec la fille
dont on rêve tous endure une belle
voiture est allée à l'école la plus
prestigieuse yelle est votre objectif
oui que tout au monde j'ai pas l'argent
pour m'offrir tout ça avec ma cousine
jeu l'accompagnent à une sorte de soi
rythme on me paye pour ça j'emmène ma
cousine quoi bon on est à cousine assure
fait pourquoi pourquoi tu le ferais une
fois le fric dont tu parlais et je veux
bien paquet ceci tu as un costard
et payer pour sortir avec une fille du
sexe que michelle obama a été payé pour
sortir avec barack et regarde le
résultat c'est vrai j'en sais rien mais
ça pourrait et c'est ce que je vais
faire
bonsoir al 11 et qu'on en finisse vite
oui ok je pensais vraiment qu'on
pourrait passer un bon moment ensemble
clairement t'as jamais fréquenté mon
lycée allons chauffer la piste de danse
mon nom
key
tu veux en faire ton métier non tu
devrais les pauvres petites riche en
quête d'un chaperon c'est un bon
business suite j'ai trouvé le moyen de
me payer la scolarité à yale j'offre mes
services de chapeau je deviendrai ce
qu'elles veulent que soit mais non tu as
passé ça aux ébats si chaque rancart
pourrait être fabriqué à la demande de
l'utilisateur choisirait ma personnalité
si je suis à l'écouté ou bavarder quoi
la chose la plus bizarre quand t'es
jamais demandé avec une fiche d'une
gamme m'asseoir sur son canapé et
l'écouter parler pendant quatre heures
et tout ce que j'étais autorisé à dire
c'était oui je suis d'accord
non mais c'est parfait ça on peut pas
dire le contraire
[Musique]
tu imagines si charavel shelby est que
je rentre ier
ça va ce serait un truc de ouf que les
gens acceptent au lieu d'accepter toi
même tu te la joues rebelles mais ce
n'est que ça on pas fait le temps
ensemble mais ça c'était avant
[Musique]
je ne sais pas quelle version de moi
même je suis supposé être voir la danse
c'est pas son truc
ouais elle est nulle j'ai pris des papes
personnalités différentes
aubry critique d'art mauvais potes
il est temps de comprendre qui je suis
et ce que je veux faire quels sont vos
autres centres d'intérêt en dehors de
l'école des trucs habituels d'ado
[Musique]